It goes without saying that celebrities have a huge influence on the general public, especially teenagers.
True, they sometimes have a positive impact.
But more often than not, their glamorous and extravagant lifestyle paints the wrong picture of what life is really all about.
One negative effect of celebrities, as concerned parents put it,...
...is that they are conveying the message, "Being thin is beautiful."
Many Hollywood movie stars boast their skinny bodies,...
...which only helps young teens have a wrong body image.
Many of them would go on extreme diets,...
...thinking that if they are fat, they would not be accepted by society.
But they should realize that rail-thin actresses and supermodels...
...do not represent the whole population.
Fortunately, a recent fashion show held in Madrid, Spain,...
...did just that by not allowing models who are too thin to be walking on the stage.
One of the people who were involved in the show...
...made it quite clear that women and teenage girls should stop starving themselves to become like supermodels,...
...as real women have curves, and curves are beautiful.